baseball bat plus head equals home my
grandmother bridges the raid to has been
one of my most requested reviews for a
long time and guys I've said this before
but I'll say it again movies that are
limited release take a little bit longer
to get to Cleveland it literally open to
day and I saw it as soon as possible
which was last night at midnight there
were a lot of fans at the screening I
took some of my friends with us it was a
perfect crowd you see this movie
everyone was just so excited for it
nobody thought the subtitles were dumb
everyone is like I just want to see this
movie and think it's amazing and guess
what
it's Christians there's a lot of really
cool stuff in here the raid 2 opens
almost immediately after the first one
ended you got this character who is just
the ultimate hardcore dude of badassery
this guy is the last man standing in any
room he walks into on the face of the
earth and in this film he goes
undercover to try to infiltrate this mob
family he gets on their side he gets
them to trust him but in reality he's
trying to learn more about the
organization and how it works it's sort
of like the departed with the raid and
Godfather 2 combined into one the raid 2
takes the best elements of the first one
and it tries to expand on it quite a bit
there's a lot more dialog in this movie
it is two and a half hours long the
first movie was only like a hundred
minutes long and it was very much just
this apartment building all the action
and the thrills and the suspense of that
some people may refer to that as a
gimmick but an extremely well executed
gimmick in every sense of the word this
movie takes that plot has all the
incredible fight sequences but it adds a
lot more characters a lot more scenes in
which you get to see these people
fleshed out sometimes the added story
the added characters and the
overabundance of dialogue does kind of
take away from the entertainment value
of the film but that's not to say that I
didn't have a great time watching the
raid too because the action scenes in
this film are truly mind-blowing the
actors had to learn how to actually make
contact with the other characters
without hurting them and varying the
speed of their punches and kicks so none
of this looks fake it all looks
extremely real to the point where I was
like oh it's like there were many times
as moving where the entire audience just
went oh
oh Jesus crazy and critters grill it's
just for those movies before the
audience needs to be involved and in a
good way and my audience definitely was
the fight scenes are incredible the
action does not disappoint this film has
one of the best car chases I have ever
seen in my life because they finally has
a filmmaker who's like hey you know what
car chases don't always have to just be
cars right we can actually have people
like on the outside of the cars and
doing stuff on the inside of cars like
my favorite chase sequence of all time
the desert chase from Raiders a Lost Ark
Steven Spielberg understood like hey
let's just have a whole bunch of guys
just everywhere doing stuff outside and
inside this truck and the cars the raid
- chase scene has very similar elements
to that and I absolutely adored that
chase scene I can't talk enough about
the action it's so well choreographed
it's so awesome their story element is
also fairly interesting there's
definitely a much more weighted dramatic
element to this film particularly in the
Sun of the overseer of this Empire he
just wants his father to give him more
respect and he's not getting it and you
get to see that eat away at him
throughout this movie in the various
decisions that he makes to try to fix
this are what set these two gangs
against each other and we have our one
hero who suddenly caught in the middle
of that as this undercover agent and
it's very riveting the action towards
the third act is unrelenting it does not
let up it's 30 minutes of absolute chaos
but it's filmed so beautifully and up
until then there's still a lot of action
sequences that are all very very well
done my flaws with this film are there
are too many extra characters
specifically one character in the film
that I feel could be removed for a few
various reasons for one he's played by
the actor who played the Mad Dog
character from the first one and a lot
of people were like wait a second I
don't understand why he's there that
character has no reason to be in the
second film without spoiling anything
and so I don't really understand why
they chose the same actor to portray a
different character I understand that he
is the fight choreographer for both of
these films and that's awesome but they
didn't really change the way he looks
he-ey the whole time I was like wait is
that the same character but that's not
that's that's not possible what what and
his entire element to the story
I understand its purpose but it did kind
of feel like an extra 20 minutes of
something that didn't really add as much
as I think Gareth Evans the extremely
talented director
wanted it to the plot elements are a
little convoluted at times and some of
the dialogue isn't as clear as it should
be however this is an extremely
masterfully crafted film it's very
stylistic in a great way
it looks beautiful the images are so
bright and clear the fight scenes are
astounding some of the best ever put to
film the raid 2 is an absolute must see
if you're a fan of action films if you
enjoyed the first one it expands upon
everything that was good about that one
too I'm gonna give the raid 2 and a - I
hope you guys check it out it is so
badass and there will be many times
Smith's movie where you're just staring
at the screen coin how did they do that
guys if you saw the first one or this
new one let me know what you thought of
it and as always thank you so much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck with
knives